all my stuff is gone look come on please
we got money for this all right come the
[ __ ] down
calm down yes calm down all right i'm
gonna say this
there are few words or phrases
that i could hear in an argument and
know
this thing is about to go from two three
to ten
more than when i hear calm down you tell
somebody to calm down
they're not gonna be calm let's just
leave it at that if you can
try to take that phrase out of your
repertoire for
arguing because more than likely it's
going to ramp them
up even more hey gq i'm stephanie yates
ayubile welcome back to part
two we'll be watching more scenes of
couples fighting
this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up shit's creek rachel and i were
engaged
but i called it off before i moved here
okay you know what
you don't need to explain yourself the
unique thing about this clip
is talking about being on different
places in your journey
with you know how open you are with your
community or your family
about who you feel you truly are and
this could be religion
this could be veganism i've seen it
where you could have a person
who eats meat but won't eat it in front
of their family member because
everybody else is vegan we got together
when we were in high school
and we we've been on and off ever since
uh i don't know we always just sort of
fell back into it anyway she's been uh
reaching out and expecting us to get
back together for the past few months
whoa it's not a question of
should he be willing to wait or should
he just come out to his family
that's not the question the question is
in the context of this relationship
which sacrifice fills the most
in line with your ultimate goals for
your future
is it more important to you to be with
this specific person
or is it more important to you to be in
a relationship where you can shout it
from the mountaintops
and be public about everything you
stood in front of me and told me to
trust people
i know when i was perfectly fine not
trusting people
not trusting people is what i'm used to
it is my comfort zone
so when it comes to a person with trust
issues which
let's face it most of us come with some
degree
of issues with trusting other people
because we've been hurt in the past
and we harp on that so that we can
protect ourselves in the future
but ultimately learning how to trust
again
that's your responsibility a person
cannot make you
trust again they can help you in your
own journey
by communicating and finding out the
things that help build trust
in these specific relationships it's
your responsibility
to first recognize you have them then
think about
what you need to do and why you have
those trust issues maybe work it out in
therapy
and thirdly be sure to communicate to
your partner things that could help
them help you as you try to become more
trusting
no matter how hard i tried with her it
just never felt right
and up until recently i didn't
understand why you make me feel right
david that is quite possibly one of the
most beautiful things
i've ever heard anyone say typically
when we're in arguments we don't even
want to
give our partners the benefit of the
doubt or compliment them
so in that moment i thought they did a
great job of providing
one another with safety like a safe
space
and security and saying i'm gonna be
open about how i feel
and they both seem to take that
cautiously they didn't throw it in each
other's face
this has really messed things up
for me and i think i need some time
with it
all right asking for patience is
definitely something you can try with
your partner
but it ultimately is up to them what
their own personal limits
are if a person feels like they've been
in this situation before
and it didn't pan out well with being
patient then you have to respect that
they are
using their own experience to guide
their decision
about whether or not to grant you that
so it's totally fine to ask for patience
but be prepared for either answer
next up big little lies why is this
still here
funny you should ask i sold it all today
oh the ted farrell nice and the best
part is
we get to keep it all a couple of things
you can see
he's enjoying making her upset when i'm
seeing
that stuff in a couple session my hope
that they're going to be able to work on
the relationship and get better
it goes down if you actually enjoy
making your partner upset or hurting
them that is
sadistic right all my stuff is gone look
come on
please we got money for this all right
come the [ __ ]
down calm down yes calm down all right
i'm gonna say this there are few words
or phrases
that i could hear in an argument and
know
this thing is about to go from two three
to ten
more than when i hear calm down you tell
somebody to calm down
they're not going to be calm let's just
leave it at that if you can
try to take that phrase out of your
repertoire for
arguing because more than likely it's
going to
ramp them up even more you lost
all our money and all the while
you've been in the nanny well now she's
gone i need something to play with don't
i
by the way i hate this scene because
there is absolutely nothing productive
to even point out
in the conversation he's egging her on
he wants her to get upset
and she sees that so you see that moment
where she's like
how can i hurt him the way that he's
hurting me
and she recognizes that he values these
toys
more than he does her so she's trying to
affect him
she wants him to hurt like she's hurting
you know i would never say this to a
couple but guys honestly can you blame
her
we all know that money is one of the top
reasons that couples not only fight but
get divorced with money whenever you're
going into a marriage you want to be
very clear
about expectations about spending habits
about how much both of you make you want
to be clear about your future goals with
money is retirement
important to you are you a
live-in-the-moment kind of person
we don't really like to think about
those things sometimes we're at the
beginning of a relationship because we
don't want to ruin
all of the good feelings that we're
having we don't want to have an awkward
conversation
we think our love can conquer all but
money is just one of those things that
love can rarely just conquer so you need
to plan
you need to strategize what we're seeing
here is that he's keeping secrets
when you start purposefully leaving your
partner out of that decision
it grows you're like well i didn't tell
them about this i don't need to tell
them about this
and the next thing you know you guys are
leading two completely separate
lives it's really important that you
clue your partner and
even if you all don't have a joint bank
account and you have your money separate
ultimately if you're living together if
you have kids together
it doesn't matter what bank accounts you
have it in your finances
affect their finances this clip really
shows
how once you have all of these lies and
secrets in a relationship
ultimately you start viewing things this
is my stuff
this is your stuff we want to hold on to
our individual identities in a
relationship
you don't want your whole identity to be
based on this relationship
but you want to view things in a
partnership as
ours you want to see things from the we
perspective
why else would you marry that person
right things need to be viewed more so
as a partnership
and you need to have shared purpose for
your resources
if you want the best chance for your
relationship to work
some people are really looking to get
married because they want to
have that status of being a wife or
being a husband or being a mom
and when you get married for those
reasons a lot of times
anything outside of that core of why you
got married feels like it's not your
partner's business
and so it's really important that even
if you did get married for one of those
reasons they
are at least clued in as to what you're
doing
because absolutely people get married
for all different kinds of reasons but
that doesn't excuse secrecy deception
and lies
next up ozark can you access
some feeling words i'm
scared i'm
terrified actually let's pause a couple
of things
the reason i love this scene is because
there is a couple's therapist
in it and i feel for her do you think
we're safe
i do think that we're safe going to help
me out here soon yeah
that'd be great can you explain to her
that everything that i do is for the
family oh and can you explain to him
that
that is complete [ __ ] we see very
early on
this is an argument about safety and i
do want to comment a little bit too
on when the therapist asks them to use
feeling words
that's a way of making sure they use the
eye position this is how i feel
and even though she did say it very
strong i'm scared
that's right that is a feeling word i'm
scared and i'm
actually terrified at this point they're
still communicating
fairly well what does it say about a
marriage
when a husband and wife both tried to
bribe the therapist
you're both paying me off the funny
thing is she says
when you both try to bribe the therapist
but then follows it up by saying you're
both paying me off so no they are
bribing you you're accepting the money
which is completely unethical she could
lose her license
absolutely do not accept any bribes from
your couples it seems like they're
trying to pull her to say that each of
them
is right and the other is wrong because
i was worried when you came back with
that crazy idea and
and i wanted sue to work a little harder
you people don't make it easy for
anybody
i've had couples try to be condescending
but no as far as somebody just
cursing me out and saying you know shut
the f up i have boundaries as well and i
cannot tell my clients to have
boundaries if i don't
have my own and enforce them too what is
wrong with you
do you get how dangerous that is
listening to michael you wanna know what
happened to the maid that lost the teeth
you're
jealous he killed her you're jealous
that's what this is about because you
can't keep up with me
no you you can't you can't see this is
where
we see that the argument is becoming
unproductive because it went from
i'm scared i'm terrified him saying i'm
trying to provide you with safety
so now you're trying to tell each other
how the other feels
when we start doing that you're not even
trying to learn how they feel
so you both have already lost the
argument when you walk away
and you don't know anything new about
your partner's perspective
i only did what i did because you didn't
have the balls to do it yourself no i
was busy trying to get us the [ __ ] out
they would have found
us they have two different approaches to
what safety looks like
her ideas let's lean in more and do more
of what they want
so we can have a future his idea is
let's get out
you know and they both are not in
agreement so if i was their therapist
i would say it seems like we have a
reoccurring theme
or it comes to you both wanting to
provide your family
and each other with safety but you have
two different strategies for
accomplishing that
and let's talk about it in that way
because there may be some compromise or
a way to understand each other's
perspective
if they see that ultimately they both
had the same
end goal i am trying to build a future
for our family out of the mess that you
created
and you're you're just you're you're too
narrow-minded and jealous to see it
right yeah and you're just a
scary selfish power hungry
i will say as far as how i
am in couples therapy i would have been
a bit more active
and de-escalating them because
to me the difference between having an
argument
and session versus having an argument in
real life
is that you have that third person there
to make you stop and be a bit more
reflective
about what it is that you're doing and
how you're communicating with each other
so i thought there were some good
opportunities in there to make them
pause
and expand a little bit more instead of
just pulling out a bunch of weapons
telling each other how the other feels
those were some opportunities for her to
kind of stop that dynamic and its track
next up my cousin vinnie i am in the
dark here with all this legal crap i
have no idea what's going on
all i know is you're screwing up and i
can't help
a lot of times in a relationship
especially
if our exclusive or primary identity is
built
in our relationship to that person when
we feel like we can't help them
that could make us feel useless so i
think this whole
film if you watch it she's actually very
very helpful to him
but she doesn't feel like she's helping
and so
when she gets into that headspace she's
really distressed and it makes her start
thinking about their future my
biological clock is taken like this
and the way this case is going i ain't
never getting married
at least i don't need this i think that
it's easy to look at this
as a woman having a frivolous goal of
getting married and he's trying to focus
on his career
but if you think about it socially women
are
taught a lot of times that our value is
tied to marriage it's tied to children
and she's basically an out-of-work
hairdresser
so her entire identity at this point is
tied up in this relationship which
is not good in and of itself but it is
and so
i absolutely think it's fair for her to
say i
am putting a lot of things on hold in
order to
keep myself available to you for
marriage so absolutely she has a right
to be frustrated with that
timeline that seems to keep getting
pushed out further and further
i got a judge that's just aching to
throw me in jail
i ain't slept in five days it's very
important to talk about
the biological or physical impact that
our bodies have on our mood he's saying
i haven't slept in five days
i'm hungry right all of these things we
need to think about when we
are about to get into an argument
because it can really drastically
impact the way that we view the
situation the other thing that
is really important to notice in this
scene
is that instead of acknowledging the
complaints or frustrations that she's
bringing
up he just matches or meets them with
his
own complaints i got no money a dress
code problem
and a little murder case which in the
balance holds the lives of two
innocent kids not to mention your
biological clock now i do think he has a
right to say this is not a good time
but for him to give his laundry list of
his issues and not respond
to anything she just said is basically
saying my problems
are more important than your problems to
him it's really important to win this
case
of course she's here to support him but
to her their future is really important
and this case seems to be the only way
she has any chance of getting what she
wants
which is marriage as a therapist my next
question to them would have been
now is this what typically happens when
you all talk about marriage
because we want to talk about what
they're talking about
and how they're talking about it that's
a really important aspect
of paying attention to the pattern for a
couple they've been together for a
really long time
and he's been tying marriage to this
impossible or imaginary goal ultimately
him winning that case has nothing to do
with their marriage
it's a very arbitrary pairing that he's
made they're probably
already living together she's out here
with him supporting him there's not
going to be a ton of change in their
relationship
based on him winning a case so i would
ask him
what is the connection between winning
this case and getting married
to really get to the bottom of why he
pairs the two
together maybe it was a bad time to
bring it up
you typically want to reserve arguments
in the moment where there is a not
active
tension and conflict so a lot of times
what we do is we get mad about something
and then we try to argue
in the moment it's better to wait till
things cool down
in a good moment arguably this could
have been considered a good moment
but what he's saying is that his stress
levels are so high that this is not a
good time for them to have this
conversation
but i don't think it was a terrible time
for her to bring it up this is a
relatively quiet moment
that it was okay to bring up something
that could lead to big conflict it just
didn't go the way that she wanted it to
go
and we never know one thing i love about
this clip
is that neither of them is saying you
feel like this
you feel like that she's saying i feel
my biological clock is ticking
i'm waiting i can't be of help and he's
saying i'm tired
i'm trying to win this case and things
like that so
they're speaking from the eye position
and that's always a good
sign of good conflict resolution and if
you watch this movie or even if you
watch this clip
there's a lot of love in this
relationship
they see a future for each other they're
just disagreeing about when that future
is going to take place she's already
here with him supporting him
during this trial so this is one of the
couples i loved
to watch because they really really good
at
showing each other that they love each
other arguments
absolutely can be constructive
we don't ever tell our couples that a
healthy relationship is when you guys
are no longer arguing
it's about being able to use that
argument as an opportunity to learn
more about your partner's perspective
why treat
your partner as like your opponent or
enemy and try to one-up them in an
argument
you're a team so whatever the issue is
you take that out of the relationship
it's called externalizing the problem
you argue about that thing and that
thing alone the only reason you're
talking about it
is so that you can figure out a solution
that can work for both parties
next up 500 days of summer or just
what but just what
just no don't pull that with me don't
even try this is not how you treat your
friend
so this is something that i'm talking
about with clients
all the time especially now with dating
apps and so much
access to people it's really hard for
people to
define what counts as a relationship and
people are
very hesitant to say you're the only
person that i'm going to be with
kissing in the copy room holding hands
in ikea
shower sex come on friends my balls this
movie was a bit ahead of its time
really depicting a situationship a
situationship
is where you're pretty much reenacting
everything or a lot of the things that
you would expect to see
in a committed relationship such as
meeting the person's family
maybe you guys even live together
holding hands in public
all of these things that you associate
with the relationship
but there is no title so you can't
really call the person your girlfriend
or boyfriend
i have clients several clients who have
been
in situationships for five plus years
and it's so hard because like he's
saying all of these things that are
typically equated to being in a
relationship with someone
now it's almost as if as long as we
don't have that title
anything goes we can do these things but
i don't have a responsibility or
obligation to you
i like you tom i just don't want to run
away well you're not the only one that
gets to saying this i do too
and i say we're a coach god damn it
the question that comes up here is well
who gets to decide if it's a
relationship and really that's the wrong
question
the thing to pay attention to is one of
you wants a title
and the other person does not want a
title you too
do not want the same things
so again we come to the question of
values
and sacrifice so is it more important to
you
to continue making memories with this
person to build on your experiences
knowing that they don't want a
relationship with you
or is it more important to you to find
somebody
else that would be willing to call you
their boyfriend or girlfriend eventually
husband or wife
there's no right answer but what they
are telling you is that you literally
cannot have both
you cannot be with me and have a
girlfriend
it's either or when we think about those
things you always want to ask yourself
do we even want the same things and if
the answer is no
how much are you willing to sacrifice to
be with this person
i typically don't see couples who come
to me in this state because you're going
to have one person like why would i come
to couples therapy we're not a couple
so what i end up seeing is one person
and they're always talking to me about
this
relationship that they're in and how can
we make it official
and they'll say to me like don't you
think we're in a relationship what do
you think about that
sure you're in a relationship but
if they're saying you guys aren't
boyfriend and girlfriend both
people have to be in agreement about
that title
if they don't accept the
responsibilities and obligations of
commitment that come with that title
then it's just a word so what we really
see here
with summer it could be interpreted as
she doesn't believe in the value
of commitment she doesn't think that's
necessary for
a fulfilling life and that's a fair
argument or we could look at it as a
fear of commitment and that's so
prevalent
today because people have so much more
access
through instagram through dating apps
you're always questioning like could
there be something better
something more and that puts people into
the position of do i really want to say
that this is my one person do i really
only want to date them i think in
today's day and age we see this
a lot more often than we even did in the
past because
everybody's terrified of missing out on
something
next up the sopranos well don't worry
i'm going to hell when i die nice thing
to say to a person heading into an mri
you know tony
i've always been sorry i said that this
is what happens sometimes when people
say
things and their feelings are hurt but
it's not talked about in the moment
here it is coming up randomly out of
nowhere
and she feels remorseful you know the
best thing you can do
when you say and do something that hurt
your partner and they finally
bring it up is to apologize now let's
see how he responds to her
carmel who did you think i was when you
married me huh
you knew my father you grew up around
dickie maltosanti and your uncle eddie
where do you get off after all surprised
when there are women on the side
when i say i'm a marriage and family
therapist the reason those two
go hand in hand is because when we get
married or we form a relationship
often we're trying to create our own
family and often
it's in response to the family that we
grew up in
so you normally see one of two extremes
either
you had a very loving home or a home
that you loved and you're trying to
imitate it and have an identical setup
which puts a lot of pressure on the
relationship
or you hated the environment you're
brought up in
and you're trying to create the exact
opposite and what we're seeing here is
he's telling her
like you know our community you know our
family you knew what the expectations
are
i do what i want i live the lifestyle i
want i
cheat but i provide you with nice things
that's the arrangement
he's basically telling her like don't
act surprised
you know we're just playing out what
we've seen generation after generation
of course when we say that these are the
expectations
that doesn't mean that those
expectations are
really what's going to make us happy or
fulfill us
she seems a little bit upset you know
and frustrated she
absolutely is entitled to her feelings
but i think
he feels justified in the lifestyle
they've been living because he feels
like she's trying to now
say it's not enough when it's been
enough for all of these other women that
they've grown up witnessing
so i honestly think that he's entitled
to his as well
just given what they grew up with every
couple has to decide
what works well for them you have some
couples who are in an open marriage
where being
sexually monogamous is not the most
important thing to them
and as long as they're on the same page
about that that's fine you have couples
where
they have an arrangement of we're
getting married for a green card and i
just need companionship every marriage
is not going to look the same there's no
right or wrong way to be married
the right way is just for you two to be
on the same page
i have been dreaming and fantasizing and
in love with furious
let's pause here i just want to quickly
compare
this scene to the scene in a marriage
story where we see him punch a wall
this was very different right she's
right by his fist
and he's trying to intimidate her and
punish her
for saying those words that leans a
little closer to emotional and mental
abuse
i could converse with her because she
had something to say i am
here i have things to say besides bring
the
chairs down did you sign the live and
trust she's a grown
woman who's been kicked around unlike me
is that it
this couple is showing so much contempt
and criticism to each other i don't know
how much
love is left if there is love in the
relationship i don't think it's mutual
when it comes to when to divorce is it
okay to divorce that is such a
subjective conversation and a lot of
times
our family plays a big part in that
decision our religion
plays a big part in that decision
because some people are going to say
never divorce and other people are going
to say you can divorce if somebody
cheats or if somebody hits you
what i will say is in a case like this
they both have invested
several years decades into this marriage
and i would say if you've been unhappy
for a majority of that time we only get
one life
so you want to really think about the
data
that you've accumulated through these
experiences and see
do you think it's worth it is it more
important to you
to have that prestige within your
community of being married for a long
time
or is it more important for you to live
and try a new life on your own there is
no right
answer it's totally based on your own
values
thank you for watching these clips with
me about scenes with couples arguing
i hope that you learned something new
about how to deal with conflict maybe
even in your own relationships
see you later